Should European countries
recognise Palestine now?
After Hamas's
unprecedented
tėrrør attack
and Israel's
deadly response
in Gaza,
many are looking
for long-term solutions
in the Middle East
Spain's acting PM
thinks the country
should start
by officially recognising
a Palestinian state
You might not know
that in Western Europe
only Sweden and Malta
have done that
Many Soviet-occupied
or ex-communist countries
in Europe also recognised
the Palestinian state
before the Soviet Union
disappeared,
as did Cyprus
in 1988,
when the
Palestine Liberation Organisation’s
Yasser Arafat
proclaimed the establishment
of the state of Palestine
Now, why would Spain
or other European countries
do this now?
Pedro Sánchez
was one of the first
European leaders
to condemn the
mass killings
by Hamas militants
and has been
much more vocal
than many of his
European counterparts
in his calls
for Israel to respect
international humanitarian law
So a few days ago
he called for the
recognition of Palestine,
saying that a
two-state solution
is the only way
out of this conflict
and to achieve
lasting “peace” and “security”
What do you think?